I want to mention something I think it's
important organizations like the World
Wildlife Fund are constantly updating
their list of the most endangered
animals from around the world one of
their jobs well tonight I thought we'd
shed some light on some other less
talked about creatures whose survival
hangs in the balance and a piece we're
calling endangered humans these are
specific types of humans that are on the
brink of extinction okay first up a very
very rare human not many left in fact
none really
it's the Samoan man who is not a lineman
in the NFL let's get him out here I'm
manager staples yes yes you from Tampa
Florida it's the last man alive to wear
an e d Hardy t-shirt he's still one left
[Applause]
the pride
Wow okay good luck finding one of these
it's an angry old white guy with no
strong opinion about Barack Obama I feel
for the guy
it's a complicated job yeah thank you
sir
[Music]
this endangered human has never been
filmed or interviewed it's the
supermodel who doesn't claim to have
been an ugly nerd in high school I
didn't hear a word she said okay this
next endangered species may be the only
one left it's the black guy named Seth
hey guys I'm Seth hi Seth good to see ya
[Applause]
now this this could be the first
confirmed sighting of an extremely rare
human it's the timid introverted drag
queen
[Music]
well through the Queen pitches hey
thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great Conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy Japanese pornography